they were satisfied with the status quo
and I'm never satisfied with the status
kill any generalist businessman could
set up any kind of business at all every
project starts out with a dream this is
a vision this is a dream it could be a
liar
I was born to in an underprivileged way
people are entitled to make mistakes
nobody's perfect if you think you're
smart there's always somebody smarter
than you we've spent nine at ten or
eleven billion dollars but who's
counting
fear theaters infected until I was 32 I
thought I could hold down the job he's
an American business magnate investor
and philanthropist he's the chairman and
CEO of the Las Vegas Sands corporation
as of June 2015 he had an estimated
fortune of twenty eight billion dollars
he Sheldon Adelson and here are his top
ten rules for success I've been working
I've been in business for 69 years since
I was 12 and every time well after the
first dozen or so businesses I realized
that the only way to get ahead was to do
things different definitely than the way
it was being done and then I came to
learn which I finally learned at my ripe
young age that if you do things
differently success will follow you like
your shadow and you can't get rid of it
so that's what I did
so people doubted me because people just
didn't do what I what I would do
it's a matter of tainted finding out
what it is that an industry does and
identify the opportunity to as to how to
do it differently and then being enough
of a risk-taker to actually do it
differently so people doubted me because
nobody thought of doing it the way that
I did and nobody had the they didn't
have the they were satisfied with the
status quo and I'm never satisfied with
the status kill my fundamental belief as
an entrepreneur
that if I were to make carpets I don't
have to be an expert or making carpets
or suits I need to know how to run a
business I'm a business journalist and I
in every business is what I call the
product area so if I hire the people
that know how to make carpets then I
could run that business just like any
other generalist business or the same
thing about suits I get other people to
fight this entrance with a lot light and
what are these principles the principles
are fundamentally think of it as a
matrix so you have a sheet of paper or a
bunch of holes in it and below we told
you is supposed to put it on something
and it helps all the dots to connect any
generalist businessman could set up any
kind of business at all okay but you
know to the eye it's going to look as
authentic as it as it looks here I'm
going to the eyelids going to look very
30 that's what I want to see we want the
eyes I think this is a this is our
challenge is our commitment I don't say
it can be done I say I'm worried okay
you're not worried oh that's it okay
okay good it's been done hey so listen
up this is Las Vegas now this is the
strip this is the Campanelli bell tower
here's the doges palace and here's the
library building Sheldon this is real
Venice
I fell in las vegas know your dream
maybe I am this is the real Venice yes
buddy oh that's right we have all the
baby dream it will be the same right I'm
making it two and a half big and all the
bet on that thinking and I believe it'll
work I'm quite confident that it's gonna
be a winner I mean there is no
equivocation in my mind whatsoever not
because I could feel it I don't know of
course I'm dreaming every project starts
out with a dream this is a vision this
is a dream I don't know I'm outspoken
because I am I could never make a I
couldn't be a liar I can only tell the
truth I would be very bad lair I say
that my father told me my father never
left me with anything material but he
left me the richest as rich as I could
be
with values and he always told me never
lie about anything you got to be honest
because if you lie about one thing the
second time somebody is going to ask you
you're going to make up a lie to cover
that first line and then pretty soon
when you've got a whole chain of lies
and then you're completely exposed
adversity is is sometimes the the mother
of invention you know when you have to
have something necessity is the mother
of invention and when it's there's an
adverse condition or conservative
conditions in a particular industry you
have to find the solution in my case I
always found I was born to in an
underprivileged way I couldn't get into
the mainstream of business where I was
born and raised in Boston because my
family didn't come over in the Mayflower
my family I was the first generation
American and my family and people who
are in business they said the banker is
the old businessman they don't allow
people like me in and I couldn't get in
so I figured a way that I had to do
something different than the way
everybody else did
these columns are done and these columns
that the hint phone that I saw that are
up they have to be taken down a read on
everybody knew that there was a certain
level of aging and anybody who thinks
that that's that is a level of aging and
weathering is simply blind so now you've
got to make sure that you redo that
piece and I'm not going to accept any
compromises whatsoever I don't want to
demoralize any of the people are working
on the job say hey you did a lousy job I
want them all feel as though they did
what they did a very good
lissa people are entitled to make
mistakes nobody's perfect all the time
displeased with the columns he summons
his team of architects to dissect the
problem leroy went through this a dozen
times that at the inside had to be
absolutely unequivocally weathered and
aged so we have to provide the
weathering and the aging immediately you
know when we install it you were the one
I am told that said make it smooth hi is
that a fair statement I said yes make it
it we picked this move but it's wrong
without any question you cannot make it
smooth I'm not sitting here to criticize
you to chop your head off I'm simply
trying to get to the bottom of it so
that we don't experience the same issue
again no I'm not a bully I resent that
I'm not a bully if I raise my boats it's
only in frustration I'm emotional I
think I would describe it as passion
into my beliefs he walks in goes right
up to the piece and this is the kind of
piece that is going to be seen from 20
to 30 feet away and he's going right up
to the very edge of it you know with a
magnifying glass and we're just like oh
my god and he's pointing out things to
us that he thought just was not
acceptable or that were incorrect as it
would be you know and so he he he just
said we'll give me a paintbrush it
starts taking off his jacket and gosh
you know I can show you what to do and
we're all like instead of telling
somebody else you go do it like in the
military they would the captain the
general would stand in the back and he'd
say well go everybody charge
I don't do it that way I say follow me
and I see that the shadows are going in
our direction
Sheldon's back to review the painting
hmm and I see that the shadows truly
reflect the shape of the leaves where
they didn't before for instance over
here these shadows these shadows were
over here listen I know absolutely
nothing about painting but I want to ask
you a question was that right
you were there were certain things that
that had to occur that you had said that
you know we're so close and in creating
the piece that it when a new eye comes
in you see different things so it was
them there's an older sometimes people
are too close to the forest to see the
trees yeah and I wasn't close to the
first do we have your approval yes you
very definitely have my people variant
ago now how about these pieces we were
very poor and my father put money he was
a cab driver when he could get a job he
only had a sixth grade education in
Lithuania not and where he came from not
here in the United States couldn't speak
English when he got here but he left me
with this with this belief that we were
poor and one day I asked him why I was
putting the money into that charity
books he explained the whole thing to me
and made me promise that I would do it
every day in my life
and as I told you I can keep the promise
per se but I did keep the promise and
spirit and and I asked him why he did
that because we were poor as well after
you explained to me he does it for the
poor people he said no matter who or
what
there was always somebody or someone
deserves someone more than you are if
you're poor there's somebody more poor
than you are if you think you're smart
there's always somebody smarter than you
and I kept our value with me till today
my parents are gone made the rest in
peace for 25 years 27 years now and but
I kept that I kept that value so
philanthropy is not its primary
responsibility but I'll see philanthropy
not necessarily will solely as a
responsibility I see it as an honor so
to support the community is both a
responsibility and an honor so being
part of the community is what you are
and therefore you have the
responsibility and you'll feel the honor
of participating and supporting the
community here it takes me a little bit
is how people look only at the short
term when my friend Steve once said I
don't want to be judged on a quarter of
a quarter basis I mean this is a
long-term investment and you can't judge
they're getting down to they're talking
about wind in MO P per day for last week
pretty soon they're going to talk about
mo P win or loss per hour right then
they'll have a reader bought up and that
will show how much is win or loss per
minute so this is all ridiculous you
know you're in business for the long
term fill a long term we've spent nine
or ten or eleven billion dollars but
who's counting and in in Macau and we're
under construction with another property
and I've asked for permission to do yet
another one non-gaming without tables I
think that I didn't invest that kind of
money just so that I could have the next
week or two weeks
I invested that money over the long term
so where does fear factor in fear fear
is infected no no such thing is fair not
to an entrepreneur concern yes fear no
you weren't frightened so really good a
Bible you didn't think I could lose the
whole shootin match here no what
motivates you to keep working as hard as
you still are you know that's an
interesting question a lot of people
don't seem to get it it habit goes back
to the time when I discovered that I was
something called an entrepreneur until I
was 32 I thought I could hold on the job
I gave it Target Babson College a
Business School in Boston to something
called the entrepreneurial exchange and
I asked the people the world 300 kids in
the audience and I said how many of you
think you entrepreneurs and everybody
raised a hand and then I asked him I
said how many of you are in the
entrepreneur business want to be in the
entrepreneur business for money
nobody's ever guessed how many people
raise their hand
too many people to guess here so I'll
tell you one that is the answer to the
question what is the reason why people
want to be entrepreneurial my answer is
the sense of achievement to a couple
something it's not the money now I'm not
going to send the money back
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because you all asked me to
so there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it in
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do I'd also love to know what you've
Sheldon Adelson's top 10 rules hit you
the hardest had the biggest impact leave
it in the comments and I'll join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon